[Música]
yo les vengo a contar la situación en la
que se encuentra el equipo de fútbol por
el cual simpatiza en particular en lo
que tiene que ver con su permanencia en
la categoría antes para aquellos que no
estén del todo familiarizados con el
fútbol les voy a contar de qué se trata
un poco esto de la permanencia en la
categoría o del famoso descenso que
seguramente escucharon como en todo
torneo en el de primera división del
fútbol argentino se confecciona una
tabla de posiciones ahí los equipos se
ordenan según los puntos que obtuvieron
en el torneo actual para eso se suman
los puntos que obtuvieron en cada
partido del torneo actual y para saber
cuántos puntos le corresponden por cada
partido se utiliza el siguiente criterio
tres puntos por cada partido ganado uno
por partido empatado y ninguno por
partido perdido así por ejemplo si mi
equipo ganó diez partidos y empató
cuatro la cantidad de puntos que va a
tener va a ser por los diez que ganó le
dan tres por cada uno entonces tenemos
los que corresponden a los partidos
empatados que dije que había empatado 4
un punto por cada partido empatado tiene
34 puntos así los equipos se ordenan
según la cantidad de puntos que tienen
de mayor a menor y el que más puntos
tiene sale campeón sin embargo hay otra
tabla que nos preocupa y que nos
interesa los que nos gusta el fútbol es
la tabla de los promedios esencialmente
en esa tabla lo que se refleja es el
rendimiento promedio de cada equipo
teniendo en cuenta no sólo el desempeño
en el torneo actual sino su desempeño en
los torneos correspondientes a las dos
temporadas anteriores y la actual cada
temporada dura un año entonces
y ese valor que va en la tabla para cada
equipo se calcula así se suman los
puntos de todos los partidos de los
últimos tres años y se divide por la
cantidad total de partidos jugados de la
misma forma que se calcula el promedio
de calificaciones de exámenes por
ejemplo cómo se hace se suman las
calificaciones de todos los exámenes y
se divide por la cantidad de exámenes
bueno acá se suman los puntos de todos
los partidos y se divide por la cantidad
de partidos así el numerito que va en
esa casilla lo que me está dando es el
promedio de puntos por partido de cada
equipo al igual que las posiciones se
ordenan de mayor a menor esos promedios
y los últimos descienden en este momento
están descendiendo los tres últimos
descienden significa que van a jugar a
una categoría inferior por eso es que
nos preocupa tanto esa tabla como les
dije yo estoy preocupada por la
permanencia en la categoría entonces lo
que les voy a mostrar es cuál es la
situación de mi equipo pero no en cuanto
a las posiciones sino en cuanto a los
promedios la tabla que les voy a mostrar
ahora corresponde a eso una tabla típica
de promedios en el fútbol
la situación de mi equipo en la
siguiente
todos los equipos jugaron 60 partidos 60
partidos teniendo en cuenta los que
corresponden a las dos temporadas
anteriores y lo que va de la actual que
todavía no termina los puntos que ven
ahí en la segunda columna corresponden a
los puntos acumulados en esos 60
partidos así por ejemplo si quiero
conocer el promedio actual de mi equipo
que el que está ahí en el medio como
hago divido la cantidad de puntos que
son 94 por la cantidad de partidos que
son 60 y me da unos 55 esos puntos
suspensivos significa que hay otros
equipos participando el torneo pero no
me interesan los que sí incluyen la
tabla son esos 3 que están abajo en rojo
porque son los que se conocen como la
zona de descenso son los que están en la
zona de descenso si el torneo termina
hoy si hoy pues el final de la temporada
esos tres equipos descienden de
categoría por suerte para ellos no
termina hoy todavía y faltan 14 fechas
por jugar sí así que todavía pueden
salir de esa zona
lo que sucede en esas 14 fechas me va a
ayudar para las cuentas que voy a hacer
para el problema que yo tengo porque
sucede que los cuatro equipos que ven en
pantalla ya jugaron los partidos entre
sí entonces en esas 14 fechas que faltan
no se van a cruzar que me implica esto
me implica que los resultados de unos y
de otros son independientes no se cruzan
podrían esos cuatro equipos ganar las 14
fechas o los cuatros podrían perder las
14 fechas sin problemas porque no se van
a cruzar entre sí y cuando digo que me
ayuda a mi problema entonces se estarán
preguntando cuál es mi problema bueno mi
problema es el siguiente
yo no quiero agarrar la calculadora
todas las fechas que faltan y ver qué
promedio tiene mi equipo me quiero
relajar es más no quiero mirar ninguno
de los otros partidos de los otros
equipos quiero mirar solo los partidos
que jueguen mi equipo y quiero saber si
yo voy acumulando los puntos en esas 14
fechas si cuando termine el torneo mi
equipo va descender o no sin mirar los
partidos a los demás obviamente una
respuesta posible sería que gane todos
los partidos
pero tampoco viene también mi equipo
como para esperar que ganes todos
entonces voy a reformular la pregunta y
voy a decir cuál es la cantidad mínima
de puntos que necesita mi equipo
acumular en estas 14 fechas para yo
estar segura de que cuando termine el
torneo no va a descender
independientemente de los resultados de
los demás no quiero depender de los
resultados de los otros partidos no
quiero ver los otros partidos quiero
saber qué cantidad en alcanzar buenos y
yo no quiero depender de los resultados
de los demás tengo que plantearme cuál
sería el peor panorama que esos equipos
de abajo le pueden presentar a mi equipo
el peor panorama para mi equipo es el
mejor para ellos que es ganar todos los
partidos que faltan si esos equipos que
están abajo ganan todos los equipos
todos los partidos que faltan sus
promedios van a subir obviamente y van a
mantener ese mismo orden entonces lo que
yo me voy a tratar de plantear es
superar el promedio óptimo es el
promedio que obtienen estos equipos
sigan
me voy a plantear superar el que está 3º
de abajo para arriba porque había dicho
que descienden tres en este caso es el
equipo que se llama a cuál sería el
promedio del equipo a si gana las 14
fechas restantes el promedio se calcula
haciendo los 73 puntos que tiene ahora
más 42 porque 42 porque dije que faltan
14 fecha si gana los 14 partidos va a
tener 3 puntos por cada partido que son
42 si 3 por 14 m datos 42 puntos
dividido la cantidad de partidos jugados
la cantidad de partidos jugados cuando
termine el torneo va a ser los que
jugaron hasta ahora que son 60 más los
14 que falta jugar 74 entonces ese es el
promedio que va a tener el equipo así
gana todos 115 sobre 74 recordemos ese
número porque ese es el umbral que yo
voy a querer superar para estar seguro
de que mi equipo no va a descender
recordemos entonces 115 sobre 74 y
entonces me preguntó qué cantidad de
puntos necesita mi equipo obtener en
esas 14 fechas para superar ese umbral
esto en matemática saben lo que se hace
que se hace para resumir una cantidad
que desconocemos y que puede describirse
con una frase larga se le pone un nombre
corto que nos permita hacer un planteo
iba a llamar x seguro muchos se acuerdan
de esa equis de la escuela que la única
función que tiene es eso resumir una
cantidad desconocida que se podía
describir de forma larga entonces esa
equis que yo busqué son los puntos que
necesito que va a tener que satisfacer
para tener que satisfacer en principio
que cuando se les agregue a los puntos
que tiene mi equipo de cálculo el
promedio en principio voy a igualar ese
umbral después veo que hago
es decir me queda eso que está ahí mi
equipo tenía 94 puntos cuando yo le
acumule esas x que voy a obtener y lo
divide por la cantidad total de partidos
que dije que era 74 quiero que iguale
ese umbral que había puesto eso que ven
ahí se llama ecuación que es una
ecuación o es una ecuación no es más ni
menos que una igualdad en donde hay un
valor desconocido y que estoy buscando
cuál es el que va que encaja justo ahí
para que esa igualdad sea verdadera
pensemos en una balanza de platillos en
donde tenemos cosas de los dos lados y
en una hay un lugar un sitio que tengo
que poner algo que haga que mi balanza
quede equilibrada es fácil ver comprobar
que si pongo en lugar de x un 21 esa
balanza me queda equilibrada porque si
miramos del lado izquierdo me queda 124
más 21 que me da justo 115 que es lo
mismo que estaba del lado derecho y
abajo los dos tienen 74 fíjense que si
pusiera un poquito menos por ejemplo 20
o menos en este caso el platillo
izquierdo me queda más livianito
entonces la balanza
equilibrada y si pusiese un poquito más
22 me queda el lado izquierdo más pesado
y entonces tampoco está equilibrada 21
es lo que equilibra la balanza 21 es el
valor que resuelve esa ecuación
qué quiere decir acá entonces si mi
equipo tiene 21 puntos va a estar
igualando a ese tercer promedio óptimo
eso tampoco me garantiza que va a estar
fuera de la zona de descenso capaz que
voy a tener que jugar un partido
desempate yo no quiero eso quiero estar
fuera entonces qué le voy a pedir a mi
equipo que obtenga 22 puntos yo sé que
si obtiene 22 punto en esas 14 fechas yo
no tengo que hacer ninguna cuenta ni
tengo que mirar ningún partido y estoy
segura que queda fuera de la zona de
descenso
qué quiere decir esto que se obtiene
menos desciende no se obtiene menos
dependo de los resultados de los demás
que es lo que yo no quería
ahora bien ahora que sé qué cantidad de
puntos necesita me voy a preguntar una
cosita más cuántos partidos necesita
ganar mi equipo para poder alcanzar esos
22 puntos recordemos que la fórmula para
los puntos se obtenía multiplicando por
3 cada partido ganado y sumando les
después los partidos empatados entonces
me preguntó puede mi equipo no ganar
ningún partido y así todo llegar a los
22 puntos no porque en el mejor de los
casos si no gana ninguno en el mejor de
los casos va a empatar los 14 la
cantidad de puntos hacer 3 por 0 porque
no ganó nada más 14 nos llegó a los 22
puede entonces ganar un solo partido y
así todo llegar a los 22 puntos de nuevo
no porque en el mejor de los casos
ganaría uno pero empataría los restantes
que son 13 la cantidad de puntos va a
ser 3 por ese que ganó 13 por los que
empató 16 no llegó
siguiendo con el mismo razonamiento me
pregunto cuál es esa cantidad que hace
que alcance los 22 bueno en vez de
llamarle x debía llamar hit para
recordarme que estoy hablando de
partidos ganados nada más le puse otro
nombre para acordarme de que hablaba esa
cantidad de g que busco tiene que
satisfacer que si la multiplicó por 3
porque me da 3 puntos por cada partido
ganado que en el mejor de los casos
empate los restantes los restantes son
14 menos los que gane quiero llegar a
esos 22 puntos que quería que ven de
nuevo hay otra ecuación una nueva
ecuación porque es una igualdad en donde
hay un valor desconocido que ahora se
llama g y que aparece dos veces del lado
izquierdo pero es lo mismo de nuevo es
fácil ver que si yo pongo en una balanza
esas dos cantidades y si donde dice que
pongo el número 4 del lado izquierdo me
queda 3 por 4 12 los que están entre
paréntesis 14 menos 4 10 22 de un lado
22 del otro y entonces ganando cuatro
partidos tengo la posibilidad
de llegar a los 22 puntos esta es la
cantidad mínima que tengo que ganar
porque considere el mejor de los casos
que era empatar los restantes o sea
ganar 4 no alcanza pero si puedo
concluir de acá que si sólo gana 3 mi
equipo no tiene forma de llegar a los 22
puntos y de nuevo voy a estar
dependiendo de los resultados de los
demás que era lo que no quería yo
como ya se habrán dado cuenta ya no
estoy hablando de fútbol estoy hablando
de matemáticas lo que pasa que la
matemática genera en gran parte de la
sociedad tal rechazo es tan resistida en
una gran parte de la sociedad que si yo
desde el comienzo les decía que lo que
yo quería contarles era que sepan qué
significaba resolver una ecuación o cómo
se razona el matemática porque fíjense
que yo analice dos problemas uno era los
dos era cantidad mínimas de algo para no
depender de otros
en el primero era cantidad mínima de
puntos para no depender de otro en el
segundo cantidad mínima de partidos
ganados para alcanzar esos puntos sin
embargo en el primer caso me plantee el
peor panorama para mi equipo que era que
ganen todos los de abajo en el segundo
me plantee el mejor panorama para mi
equipo que era empatar los restantes es
decir que con esto les también les
quería mostrar que en el razonamiento
matemático no hay recetas que uno sigue
sino que va planteando el problema de
acuerdo al contexto usando lógica
pero de nuevo si les decía desde el
comienzo que quería hablar de ecuaciones
y de lógica matemática quizás muchos ni
siquiera hubiesen intentado escuchar lo
que yo iba a contar porque la matemática
genera esto genera que piensen que a
veces hablamos en otro idioma un idioma
inaccesible y yo con esto les quería
mostrar que a veces es posible saltar
esa barrera idiomática desde un problema
concreto llevarlo al lenguaje matemático
traducirlo al lenguaje matemático
resolverlo y volver con el resultado del
contexto del problema y podría haber
elegido cualquier cosa para eso pero no
elegí de casualidad el fútbol elegí el
fútbol porque estoy convencido de que
tenemos que poder aprovechar lo que el
fútbol genera en una gran parte de la
sociedad y transformarlo transformarlo
sobre todo sin dudas lo más importante
en valores eso generaría un gran cambio
en la sociedad teniendo en cuenta la
cantidad de chicos y chicas que se
encuentran en formación en los cientos
de clubes del país y del mundo si
logramos transmitir valores ya el cambio
sería increíble pero también podemos
transmitir conocimientos
la historia música arte biología
matemáticas y en este camino de ver al
fútbol como una herramienta de
transformación encontré mucha gente que
piensa lo mismo y una de ellas es una
escritora y periodista argentina llamada
miguel a la cruz y es justamente con una
frase de ella que quiero cerrar la
charla porque considero que resume con
palabra justa esta idea de ver al fútbol
como una herramienta la voy a leer
ella dice es necesario construir un
fútbol que incluya que enseña a resistir
a ser valientes a imaginar a jugar y a
pensar para no ser aplastados muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]